the reason i hate going on flights and
sitting on the window seat is
i hate not being able to access the
toilet under my own will oh i do
i i know now my limits of my own bladder
so now whenever i'm on a long flight i'm
like i'll seat
give me a higher seat immediately i
don't have to look at the view i've seen
yeah i know what the outside of a plane
looks like i know i know what sky looks
like i don't need to look at sky
i i know what a city looks like from
above i will sacrifice
all right hold up okay this is gonna be
our first topic for [ __ ]
listen i am a firm window seat
fan why why i'll tell you why because
right
what's the biggest downside of being in
the aisle gentleman what is it come on
there's got to be one yeah inside
because there is no there [ __ ] that you
don't
you don't see one there is one glaring
gigantic
annoying issue and that is [ __ ]
people in the window and middle seat
wanting to get out
and and god forbid they're [ __ ]
clumsy as [ __ ] and they're like oh
oh like [ __ ] falling over everything
and then they've got like 10 [ __ ] that
they got on their lap they got like the
whole [ __ ]
family buffet and [ __ ] they got like 10
headphones portable charger it's like
for [ __ ] sake put it in your [ __ ]
bag they're trying to shimmy around
like get that [ __ ] away from me i want
to go in the window because i want to
sleep and i don't want to be disturbed i
but you're okay with disturbing
disturbing yeah because
that just shows like the difference in
mentality because i would rather i'm i'm
fine with being disturbed i'm just like
going to go to the toilet man i know you
need it's
i don't know if everyone else sees it
the same way as i do because i know that
i get
annoyed by minor things my house could
burn down and i'll be like well that's
[ __ ] that's really inconvenient that
hasn't it
but if someone moves in the aisle seat
for [ __ ] sake
no because for me there's like there's
like a counter like because
i i know how much i piss i mean i'm glad
that i don't need to worry when i
how much i piss on trash taste because i
piss a lot on trash taste yeah
but in the confines of an airplane
you are stuck there and you ask to go to
the toilet once
all right that's reasonable right
everyone has everyone knows
everyone needs to go to the toilet yeah
but twice okay that's that's that's kind
of pushing it you know
what if i need to go three times when
everyone's sleeping what if what if that
just happens oh you're more worried
about pissing them off yeah
i'm more worried about this picture
you're on the you're on the aisle
what is the limit before you start to
get annoyed with how many times people
get up to go and pee
it doesn't matter because i mean no
matter what i'm going to be pissing more
yeah
these two people combine for me for me
for me i i never get pissed off because
i'm like i get him
i know the pain that's my i know the
trouble you're in i got your brother
that's my mentality right the isle
people the isle chumps are used to being
annoyed that's my theory right so
i don't really feel bad about disturbing
i'm [ __ ] zen on the all you know
the middle c just lose so yeah i mean
they already knew they already knew they
lost
the middle c is just the loser's seat no
one ever wants to sit in the middle c
unless i think that you're a [ __ ]
psychopath if you actually choose to
sit in the middle see well this is like
okay well i mean you know when you're
the only time i don't give a [ __ ] about
middle c is if we're on like an hour or
two flight i'm like
yeah yeah that's fine literally i
watched one jason statham
there yeah right but i mean i do care on
a 12-hour flight
but you've already lost at that point
and you should have pre-booked that's
your fault yeah exactly
exactly but do you ever do that gamble
where you're like i want the whole
road to myself this plane looks just
empty enough where i think i can pull
this off
you're like i'm gonna book just a middle
seat in a clean row of three
no i know no that's the i like to live
life on the edge because then i know
that
what what sick [ __ ] is going to want to
sit next to a madman that would
willingly choose the ilc in a row of
three that should sound dangerous
i should like speed like a danger sign
no because what i do
is that i i get the safe seat of just an
aisle seat because i know that no matter
what even if that aisle is full
i get the extra leg room i get immediate
access to the toilet i don't disturb
anybody
and win like like but then the moment i
get on the plane
and i see oh not a lot of people waiting
in this in this waiting
room right now right then then that's
when i go like so uh
how many how many aisles are open today
how many hours can i can i sneak into
one of those and like i just asked and a
lot of the times they're just like yeah
that's when it's that's when it's empty
and also i don't ask i just go oh okay
the moment the plane like the seat belt
things come on i'm like that's a free
aisle that's mine i i could see other
people on the plane i see their eyes
looking at the free seats i'm like now
it's mine
i'm getting everything i'm like
get down well that's the other benefit
of being in the aisle right you
immediately just go
but yeah i mean it's it's rare that i've
been i'm on a plane where it's like
the where there's an aisle there you're
like i'm pretty sure the gamble you're
making is like
it's like [ __ ] gotcha odds i am
talking about when the plane is like
basically like 70 to percent full right
yeah
right because again like i said no one
if you if you're on the booking page of
the plane you get to see the layout as
you do
you're not gonna sit next to the guy who
picked willingly in the middle because
that's a bad sign i wouldn't do that if
i saw someone in the middle i'm like
he's a psychopath
that's a psychopath he wants to
socialize
yeah i'm like no no no no no no i'm not
falling for this
i'm not here to [ __ ] socialize i
don't want to join a cult today i'm sure
i'm sure there'll be some cults
yeah yeah but then i don't mind going on
the okay so okay okay i'll do that
gamble if
it doesn't work out i might i might go
to the like whoever's next to me like
you want to swap
i want to swap you actually yeah
sometimes i'm like listen
i'm going to sleep do you want to swap
and then they're like yeah